quels moyens pour le retour à l'emploi
des 13500 allocataires du RSA en
Indre-et-Loire débat au cœur de la
session du conseil départemental
aujourd'hui le département qui veut
réduire sa participation aux dispositifs
d'accompagnement tollé à gauche la
session avec pourtant débuté sur un
consensus Justino
alors que l'inflation galope le Conseil
départemental a voté ce matin une aide
financière pour les associations d'aide
alimentaire du territoire on a l'entrée
d'un hiver très difficile inflation
augmentation du prix des dunes
élémentaires du prix de l'énergie donc
on a mis 180000 euros après une
constatation avec toutes les
associations caritatives c'est une somme
importante mais c'est pour permettre à
toutes les personnes qui ont avoir
besoin de cette alimentation sur une
année c'est 10% des détour en jeu d'y
avoir droit les associations les plus
subventionnées sont les Restos du Coeur
le Secours populaire et la Banque
alimentaire de Touraine qui recevront
chacune 50000 euros du département une
initiative approuvée par l'opposition
même si celle-ci voudrait aller plus
loin l'aide alimentaire ne répond pas à
tous les enjeux de la précarité
alimentaire c'est pour ça que je demande
on nous demandons à qu'on ait une
réflexion d'avoir une stratégie pour
lutter contre la précarité alimentaire
autre pointe à l'ordre du jour la
révision du programme départemental pour
l'insertion et l'emploi votez le 24
votre juin dernier il encadre notamment
le nombre de places d'accompagnement
pour les bénéficiaires du RSA prenant en
compte l'ouverture de 1110 nouvelles
places financées par l'État via Pôle
Emploi le nombre de sels financées par
le Département va être réduit de 15 %,
ce qui inquiète l'opposition la
situation économique est compliquée le
nombre du bénéficiaires de RSA peut
augmenter avec la crise qui se profile
devant nous donc pour nous c'est
vraiment pas le moment de baisser la
garde je dirais au niveau du département
mais pour la majorité l'accompagnement
ne sera pas à moindre riz il y a pour
une fois il faut le saluer une une aide
importante de l'État qui a accroît
fortement ce effort donc il n'y a pas de
baisse de l'accompagnement il y a un
changement dans l'accompagnement
actuellement en Indre-et-Loire
13500 foyers sont allocataires du RSA